monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je suis
ravie de prendre la parole ici devant
vous afin d'évoquer la situation de nos
territoires ultramarins ce rapport tout
comme les autres publiés par la
délégation sénatoriale mais en lumière
des problématiques qui sont souvent
propres aux outre-mer et parfois
malheureusement méconnu sur le plan
national j'en veux pour preuve la
situation des ports dans nos régions
grâce à leur position stratégique ces
infrastructures pourraient devenir des
pôles importants pour le transport
mondial pourtant à l'exception de port
réunions qui figure parmi les quatre
meilleurs ports français les autres
méritent sérieuses efforts de
modernisation au travers de la réforme
portuaire de 2012 marquée par la
création des grands ports maritimes le
législateur à grandement amélioré le
fonctionnement des ports toutefois ces
poumons économiques sont au manque de
moyens permettant de s'adapter à
l'explosion du trafic par porte-cont en
Guyane par exemple les navires sont
déchargés essentiellement avec les grues
de bord faute de portique ou de grue sur
les quais la lenteur de ces opérations
impacte le coût du fret et par
conséquent grève le budget des ménages
guyanais nous devons garder à l'esprit
que ces ports permettent de sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des biens de
consommation et des matériaux de
construction pour des populations qui
sont extrêmement dépendantes de
l'extérieur très riche et instructif le
rapport de la délégation préconise de
nombreuses pistes comme un port flottant
extérieur pour le plateau d'aiguillages
voir l'évolution du statut du port
langoni de Mayotte lorsqu’un certain
nombre de freins auront été levés chers
collègues nous avons le devoir de rester
vigilant car ces ports demeurent la
principale et parfois l'unique porte
d'entrée de nos territoires j'entends
profiter de cette tribune pour évoquer
un autre dossier sensible la pêche les
professionnels Guyane et ont profité de
ces auditions pour exposer une situation
catastrophique ils doivent faire face à
une baisse importante de la production
en raison d'une pêche qui est illégale
non déclarée et non réglementé cette
activité intensive est généralement le
fruit de navire étranger venu du Brésil
ou du Suriname nous n'avons les efforts
de la Marine nationale les moyens
doivent être réajustés pour accroître la
pression sur les navires étrangers
actuellement l'État ne consacre 120
jours à cette lutte dans les eaux
guyanaises contre une présence de 300
jours dans le canal du Mozambique une
différence de traitement qui interpelle
les professionnels car ils doivent faire
face à des pêcheurs étrangers de plus en
plus violents même les actions maires de
la Marine nationale sont comparés à des
opérations de guerre chers collègues
j'en parle ici avec émotion car la
filière a perdu il y a quelques mois son
chef de fil Georges Michel Caram qui
s'était battu pour la préservation de la
pêche en Guyane et cette filière assure
encore l'approvisionnement de la
population produit de la mer mais pour
combien de temps encore je vous remercie
de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]